they've you know been very clear
that they don't want me in this election
I hear it from people all the time you
know why don't you
um you know you can hurt Joe Biden you
know again and get Trump elected
um you know people say that to me a lot
since you have a you see a bit of a
connection between say some of the
coverage that you get in places like the
New York Times and your criticism of uh
the agencies and things like that like
you see this as sort of one Insidious
web which I think is deeply also
connected to the Democrat Party these
days I mean the fact that you're polling
in some places over 20 percent right now
and they are making it very very clear
that they're not going to put you on a
debate stage I mean a lot of Democrats I
think are not happy about this I know a
lot of Republicans are not happy about
it and they're happy to talk to you
yeah I mean I you know I think you know
one one of the things I said
in my um in my speech my announcement
speech in Boston is that the people are
normally put in charge of these agencies
and and this was what Trump did too
you know Trump came in and he promised
to train the swamp and then you know he
put me he named me as head of the
vaccine safety Commission
and I started that function I met with
fauji I met with Collins and was putting
together that you know project and then
uh when that news got out
Pfizer gave a million dollar
contribution to Trump and uh and Trump
appointed to Pfizer's hand-picked
candidates Alex Azar
around HHS and Scott Gottlieb who was a
partner of Pfizer to run FDA and you
know Godly came in there uh in an 88
billion dollar gift to of operation warp
speed for for Pfizer and then left
to join Pfizer board and get his
collector's payoff so you know that is
the swamp and and uh you know uh people
come in wanting to change it but they
get intimidated by these big agencies
and they um uh and they you know get
frightened because yeah the agency can
hurt you you know if you go after that
agency
there's a lot of top level officials in
there who can commit all kinds of civil
disobediences that will embarrass the
president and so what they do is they
appoint somebody who's safe they look at
the agency they say I'd like to change
that but I got other agendas
they leave the whole you know instrument
of corruption intact
and they appoint somebody who's safe
and that person you know Ralph Reid once
said to me the guys who get those jobs
are the guys who who get the joke you
know
right right I said in my announcement
speeches I get the joke but I don't
think it's funny you know right exactly
and I'm not safe no I'm not you know I'm
my job is to keep the American people
safe
but I'm not going to be safe with a
status quo I'm going to be the worst
nightmare for the status quo
so for all the people that hear you the
independence the what I would say are
the remaining sort of old school
liberals and for even some conservatives
who are open to a lot of these ideas and
a lot of the stuff you're talking about
it's it's sort of trumpian in a certain
sense it's stuff that Tucker Carlson
talks about I want to get to the Ukraine
war in a second
um but what would you what's the way to
get you on that stage so that there can
be a debate between you and Joe Biden
because to me the the difference would
be so Stark that that could start the
Avalanche like that seems to be the
chance
what can you do with the Democrat Party
in essence is what I'm asking you know I
think we need to go the Democratic party
into into a debate I mean we're
we're at a period in history where you
know so many Americans no longer believe
in the political process they think is
rigged against them and you know the
Democratic party or and the Republican
Party ought to be doing their best
to Showcase gold standard elections
and to tell you know the American people
democracy counts your vote counts your
opinion counts
and we're actually going to do retail
campaigning we're gonna
have to base we're gonna you know we're
not going to be like the Soviet Union
where you know with a party would pick
the candidate and tell you you know
here's who you voted for and there's no
real contest going on and no real choice
this is America we're we you know we
model democracy for the world we should
have a model you know a role model
election in this country and you know
let's
you know we need to tell Joe Biden and
you know to embrace the ideals that he
stood for for his whole career and not
end his career by you know tarring our
country with a with a you know with a
rigged election this
the Democrat are you in any contact with
the Democrat Party I mean have you have
they specifically said we're not gonna I
mean I'm guessing they don't pick up
your calls right oh no we're not in
contact with them I mean they've you
know been very clear
they don't want me in this election I
hear it from people all the time you
know why don't you
um you know you could hurt Joe Biden you
know and get Trump elected
um you know people say that to me a lot
you know people who are in the party or
uh you know I ran into Hillary Clinton
at a dinner a couple of weeks ago and
she said something like that to me
along those lines
um and you know and it's it's strange
because most
um
I don't think anybody is happy with the
choices that Americans are being given
right now and I think you know we need
some other choices I'm glad Marianne
Williamson is in this race I hope Gavin
Newsom gets into it I think you know we
need choices we need we can't just have
a Kabuki theater you know democracy we
need we need a real you know we're
supposed to be the Democrats supposed to
be the party of the new deal not the
party of the rig deal and that's I have
to my audience my audience will go crazy
if I don't say something though about
Gavin Newsom because he to me is exactly
why I'm no longer a Democrat the reason
I literally fled California because of
him high taxes endless regulation
lockdowns keeping his Winery open like
so I'm I'm with you that you need a
diverse broad Coalition of people and
different ideas and all that stuff but
that guy I I just I would be remiss if I
did not say that but I love that because
I that's when I want to run I want to
have that discussion with him I want to
sit on a stage
and say exactly what you just said
because you know we should have thought
that working people involved in this
debate you know I want people who I
don't agree with
and I also want to say the show that we
can have a civil discussion with each
other even though
you know you know even though we have
these profound disagreements you know I
there's nobody who disagrees more with
the way the way that
um that Gavin uh Newsome ran uh the
covet operation and you know I was in
San Francisco this week and I spent
like I guess almost nine months in in
San Francisco during the Monsanto trials
so you know I I got to know the city
really well and loved the city
and the courthouse is near enough Union
Square and that I could walk down to
Union Square every morning
and you had you know Union Square for
people who don't know San Francisco it's
like the Fifth Avenue of San Francisco
it's where all the cops you know Armani
and Nordstroms and uh Banana Republic
and GAP and
and all of these you know powerful
iconic American corporations so the
Showcase of American retail might is
right there you know Levi's and and uh
and all of these and it is it is Fifth
Avenue West
and I went out there three weeks ago at
every one of those shops is closed every
one of them and it you know these are
huge buildings and giant malls and
Retail and they're just closed
they're boarded up because they you know
they just let they they let them
language during these lockdowns that
just destroyed the city there's a third
30 35 vacancy rate then there's no way
that they're you know I don't even
understand
any conception of how they can bring
that City back
you know you need somebody I don't know
you need some very very powerful dynamic
character
who can come in and and convince these
retailers that you know that the
policies are going to change and that
they they can take a risk on California
on San Francisco again and that's all
Gavin Newsom
and I want to talk to them about that I
want to talk on a stage you know about
what do you think that's good for
America you know are you happy if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell